معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس ماذا في اخر تطورات الميدان
والخطط الاسرائيليه بشان تطورات
الحرب السي اولا هنالك تحليق كثيف
للمسيرات الاسرائيليه في اجواء المنطقه
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه في الساعات الاخيره
حيث تسمع من تلك المناطق ايضا اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله في اكثر من موقع
وفي اكثر من مكان وهذه هي المناطق حقيقه
السي المستهدفه في الايام الماضيه الضواحي
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وكذلك الضواحي
الجنوبيه الغربيه منها وان كان ايضا وسط
المدينه يتعرض بين الحين والاخر الى قصف
مدفعي واحيانا الى غارات جويه كما كان
الحال يوم امس واليوم الذي سبقه
وهذه المناوشات وهذا القتال ما زال مستمرا
الان في الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه هنالك
بعض سحب الدخان التي تتصاعد في المناطق
الاقرب الى الجهه الغربيه من المدينه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان قوات الفرقه
162 التي تعمل في المناطق الشماليه ما
زالت تقوم بعمليات عسكريه محدوده في
المكان وفي الزمان وهي مبنيه بالاساس على
معلومات استخباراتيه تقدمها شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه وكذلك ما يقدمه جهاز
المخابرات الداخليه المعروف باسم الشباك
من معلومات استخباراتيه العمليات هنا
تتركز بحسب ال الجيش ال
الاسرائيلي اذا نرى هذه الغاره الان
الجويه في نفس المكان الذي كنا نتحدث عنه
السي المناطق الوسطى لمدينه غزه اذا هذه
غاره جويه جديده الان تستهدف هذه المناطق
التي حقيقه كان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي قد
استهدفها اكثر من مره في الايام القليله
الماضيه وعلى مدى الاسابيع الماضيه لكن
بشكل مكثف حقيقه في الايام الماضيه هنالك
تركيز كبير على الضواحي الجنوبيه للمدينه
كذلك الضواحي الغربيه ووسط المدينه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه في خضم هذه العمليات
ويحاول الوصول الى منصات الصواريخ التي
تطلق منها المقاومه الفلسطينيه صواريخها
باتجاه منطقه غلاف غزه بالتحديد والتي لم
يتمكن من تحييدها في اطار العمليات الكبرى
كما ان العمليات العسكريه اسرائيليه هنا
محدوده في اطار عمليات التمشيط ومحاوله
الوصول الى فتوحات الانفاق والانفاق
الهجوميه وما تبقى من مستودعات اسلحه يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه يحاول الوصول اليها
وتدميرها من ناحيه اخرى الجيش الاسرائيلي
في المنطقه الجنوبيه يقول بان عملياته ما
زالت على زخمها وتشارك فيها خمسه الويه
تحت امره الفرقه 98 اشكرك من غلاف غزه
مراسلنا الياس كرام